today we're exploring one of the most
popular fads to hatch
you heard me since the pandemic raising
backyard chickens and some people don't
know where to begin
but we've got you covered so it is time
for
chicken cooping 101
and joining us today is backyard chicken
keeping expert kathy shea mormino
aka the chicken chick hi
kathy hi drew how are you what you got
there
i have your beautiful little baby here
so i think you have ebony and her
partner
ivory is in there now kathy raising
chickens are all the rage but
were you surprised to see this trend or
were you like
i've been here all along well yeah i
mean i think
backyard chickens i've been saying for
years are the new family dog
so people looking to get
back to our roots our sis are you know
finding out sustainability by way of
growing our own food
chickens for eggs gardens etc
it all makes sense that people want to
know where their food is coming from and
chickens are a pretty
pretty easy pet to raise
[Laughter]
and you know in the same way people
started
making sourdough bread and banana bread
during the
you've got that beyonce thing going like
naturally anyway
i need to stop looking like this and be
like yeah
um on the wings of an eagle i
now eat all the eggs i'm extremely
passionate about
the chickens because we raised them
since they were baby baby chicks
we gave them all names and i've been
through
uh several seasons with them now um
like full circle they're over a year old
okay
and that's them that blanche of course
right doesn't she look like a blanche
and then i've got ramona percy pepper
uh that's ferdinand and we got
all different that's pepper now i love
this coop design
and i built a coupe myself
and i just basically took a garden shed
and cut a hole in the door like in the
wall and created a door for them
and just transport transformed it this
is the chicest little coop i've ever
seen what is this all about
well this is like giving me martha
stewart for chicken coop so
so go with that vibe but then build in
safety and security and a couple things
that are really important to remember
about
chickens is that where they sleep at
night inside the coop should be the
safest place they ever
are they're they have very few defense
mechanisms and if something gets in
there
they're done they have poor night vision
so they can't see a thing and so their
chicken coop needs to be predator proof
and we talk about predator proofing with
welded wire that's
hardware cloth or welded wire i put a
roof on mine because the
hawks can come down and pluck them right
out and i said no
no um and i eventually when it was safe
and i could have someone come to the
house
i built some boxes inside with little
wooden ladders and it now looks like a
professional chicken coop
so now when you have a day off i want
you to go in with your reciprocating saw
again and put windows on all four sides
of your coop
really and a really really important
take-home message
is the reason why because these birds
have core body temperatures ranging in
the 104 to 107 degree
fahrenheit range and they're wearing
down jackets
all day every day now kathy as we're
going to go into commercial
i would love for you to and i to make
like a one minute pitch
for why having chickens are so great you
go first kathy give a one minute pitch
on why having chickens
is a really wonderful thing so chickens
are a wonderful thing
because they're the only pet that
produces
food and everything
else that they produce is also useful so
their
manure once you compost it is amazing
nitrogen-rich garden material for your
flower beds for your vegetable gardens
and
they are just overall great pets they
are the new family dog kathy i'm so glad
i asked you
and i second everything you say and i
will also say that
for me and my daughters to raise these
little baby chicks we all felt like
parents together
whereas usually i'm their mom and
they're the kids and instead we all
became little mother hens
and i've just come to love them so much
i
love their eggs i love taking care of
them
and it's simpler than i would have
thought it seemed like a really daunting
thing
and it's actually brought me in a
tremendous amount of pleasure in life oh
that's that's wonderful and
i hear that all the time and that's how
it should be well i also think if you
need a wind machine at your next photo
shoot
like come on here we go ready ebony is
on it ebony
give me let's have it let's beyonce this
ebony
there we go um i just want to thank you
kathy
and the fact that your top is yellow the
signature color of our show
matching these beautiful yellow wreaths
you've brought so much joy to our show
and i really do encourage
people to have chickens my pleasure and
everybody starts somewhere
none of this is intuitive these birds
don't come with a manual when you pick
them up at the feed store when you show
up in the
in at the mail room and um
but you can read my book so there's that
i would say there is
there is a manual now but there wasn't
one i think this is the name of your
book cathy we want to put it on our
website
absolutely it's the chicken chicks guide
to backyard chickens
simple steps for healthy happy hens go
to the drewberrymore show.com to get
kathy's book
um i cannot wait i'm going to read it
cover to cover thank you kathy so much
my pleasure thanks for having me thank
you ebony
you